the abyss I heard the story that Ed
Harris almost died cuz he ran out of
oxygen when he was swimming to one of
those tanks or something there there was
no oxygen and he barely made it is that
true I don't know you never heard about
that I've heard Ed tell it well when I
say I don't know I Ed you can go online
and listen to Ed talk about exactly what
happened to him and I think more than
anything else there was a mix up
underwater and a safety diver got to him
and didn't put uh the octopus in right
into his mouth and uh he sucked up some
and it happened to Jim Cameron too um
there was a time when we were shooting
we a 30ft tank and uh we're at the
bottom and we don't we you know we're
not in SCU scuba gear we got these masks
on we got weights on our feet and it's
kind of like you know you're walking
along it's kind of like being on the
moon you kind of bounce around and was
fun I really enjoyed that movie I had a
great time the only time the only thing
that I didn't like about was I wasn't
always on the set right you know cuz I
was playing the bad guy so it was a lot
of the other what about the boots stay
with the boots uh oh yeah so so anyway
we're so so we're working and you know
they have lights underwater however they
figure that out you know we're working
and we've been doing it for weeks and
weeks and weeks at and working
underwater and doing different stuff and
it's a huge tank millions and millions
and millions of gallons of water and
they put these beads on the top cuz the
light was coming through and they Jim
wanted to be able to light it properly
so they put all these little tiny beads
and it was all black on top so no light
would come in and we're down there and
uh we had an underwater uh uh oxygen
tank that you just plug into and you get
you fill up your oxygen and then you you
know then you're off and you're
wandering around and until your shots
ready you're bouncing around you know I
used to you know I told you I was a wake
and bited guy for 40 years or whatever
you know and I I had a blast I had a
great time especially doing the
underwater stuff um but nothing happened
so what happened was like all of the
sudden it just everything went black
like all they lost all
power uh to to and there
were four three or four actors under
there the entire crew but they all have
scuba gear on they have sco they could
just you know no no and it it went from
like me talking to you to you like
closing your eyes I mean that's scary it
was it was weird weird I mean I have
oxygen but the first my your first
thought is well how much oxygen did I
have you know and then as time goes by
it's like it's dark I don't know where
we are I don't know how much oxygen I
have what the f is going on so for did
you hear no of course not underwater no
I thought maybe they had like
little no they did well Jim could talk
to us but but no nobody was
communicating how long were you there I
was we were there for probably about 2
minutes which like eternity it seemed
like a long time and then I thought to
myself Michael you have a practical
light on you and a practical light is
one that your character would use in a
movie they call it a practical light
right so I'm like oh my god I've got my
flashlight deal so I pull that out I
turn that on and people started just
coming toward me you know because I was
the only light underneath there after 2
minutes of people going what the
the safety D came all the everybody all
every everybody everybody who was down
there came and
because nobody had one except for my
practical light and then Jim kind of
rounded us all out and with hand signals
and stuff said like you know follow me
we're going to go out this way and uh so
like Jim Cameron to the rescue as always
he was the man I me if you're ever in a
foxhole you want to be in a foxhole with
that guy and uh you know nobody was
expecting it and it was scary it was
scary uh but um uh you know as as Jim
was leading the group and we were all we
all held each other we were all like
lined up holding each other and Jim was
you know he knew you know geographically
where he was and how to get out and uh
by the time you know 30 or 40 seconds of
doing that all of the sudden everything
all the lights came back on again so
that was that was a scary experience for
me that is crazy